you had so many experiences that other
people
can can only faintly dream of what that
would be like
to to be like carrying the hopes and
dreams of like oh like you know
uh of um like an entire people
like obviously it's nowhere near the
scale of running for president
right but for me i think as i reflect on
my journey
it has been a complete balancing act
from beginning to end
which is how do i embrace my culture
but in a way you know do i want to be
defined by it
and it's and that's the thing you know
what i mean like i'm never i'm never
going to shy away from the fact that i'm
asian american
but at the same time i also don't want
to be just seen
only as yo you know he's an asian rapper
and that's why we need to pay attention
to him
it's a balancing act so in terms of
what's going on right now you know
i feel like there's a unity within that
community that that i've never seen
right and as far as everybody
galvanizing
their energies collectively to tell our
stories
to to have a voice so i'm excited in
that you know because
i i think i've always looked at my
journey as my journey right like oh this
is my journey i started rapping
but unbeknownst to me yo my journey has
been
a lot of people's journey it's our
collective journey
[Music]
welcome back to yang speaks it's your
co-host zach grauman
we're glad you guys are back we've got
the one and only
mcginn the musician the rapper i'll
never forget mcginn
made a yang gang anthem when we were
running for president
and not a lot of you we played it in the
bus
way more often than we should have but
they talk about his career
how he started on bet he's an amazing
guy
please welcome mcginn to yank speaks
[Music]
[Applause]
all right 2020 showed us a lot shows a
lot of things but of anything
it showed us that we never know what
life is going to throw at
us and if you use credit cards to pay
for unexpected expenses it can be
overwhelming to manage that debt
so take control with upstart so you can
know exactly
what to expect when you're paying off
credit card debt so upstart is a fast
and easy way to get a personal loan to
pay off your debt
all online so whether that's paying off
credit cards highly consolidated uh
high interest debt funding personal
expenses over a half a million freaking
people have used upstart to get simple
fixed monthly payments they consolidate
all they use lots of different
inputs to evaluate a different type of
credit score for you
they find smarter rates with trusted
partners and they assess more than just
the credit score which i love find out
how upstart can help lower your monthly
payments today when you go to
upstart.com
yang that's upstart.com yang don't
forget to use our url
and let them know we sent you the loan
amounts will be determined based on your
credit
income and certain other information
provided in your loan application that's
upstart.com yang
[Music]
[Applause]
it is my pleasure to welcome to the
podcast
musician artist actor
trailblazer pioneer charter member of
the yang gang the man responsible for
some of the coolest [ __ ]
that comes out of the presidential
campaign mcginn
welcome what's up finally
i'm here chilling with andrew there's no
limit to what we can do
we don't have no plans true but we will
come through
and make sure that this podcast is one
of the best
now that's no disrespect to the rest but
i know that
to be here speaking with you i am truly
blessed yes
oh my gosh so that's how the man
uh 116th and park over and over again
and became this uh
um hip-hop rising star
legend urban legend back in the day
i i've been so looking forward to this
gin
and i associate you with some of the
best times on the presidential trail
uh because any time i saw you it was at
some rally
in l.a or in new york uh you know
there's like a crowd of like hundreds or
thousands and uh you would go and rock
it
yeah great memories you know if nothing
else for me
uh you know just that that's a great way
to kind of segue into man how i
discovered you
uh and just the organic fashion of how i
got to know you
and how we ultimately uh uh like
formally cross
paths i mean everybody's yang gang story
is different right but for mine
nobody was like hey this is the thing
you gotta join it
like it didn't nobody had to hard sell
it to me i discovered it on my own
and i think the key part was um the book
right the war on normal people
and i have this you know kind of funny
uh
just thing that i like an inside joke
that's with inside myself
is that as i discovered more about you
and i would cross paths with people in
the yang gang
they would all say um yeah i learned
about him through the joe brogan podcast
have you seen the joe rogan podcast and
i was like no i haven't seen it
and it became this ongoing thing that
the more people said to me have you seen
it
i was like no and i'm not going to watch
it i feel like
i'm going to withhold it's it's funny
jim because we had the reverse joke on
the trail during that time
where like everyone who was coming was
like hey joe rogan podcast
i kind of feel like i'm part of a
special breed that
yo i i am i i i hooked on to the yang
gang
without the joe rogan podcast right so
shout out to everybody else that's in
that same category but nonetheless i i
did hear that that
that podcast was a a a great
introduction
to you your vision you know what you
know what you're you're trying to bring
to the table
and and you know kind of overall picture
of who is this andrew yang got you know
but in terms of actually meeting you
because this one thing when i read the
book
it's one thing when i'm watching you on
the news clips and and the interviews
but i think to be at a rally to be able
to introduce you on stage to perform you
know
you know true gang that's who i hooked
up with
drew yeah and as soon as it clicked i
was like yo nobody's done this
well here i am and that's when i found
that's when i found my purpose in life
you kidding man i mean you've had your
purpose and i really want to get into
this because
you are such a pioneer for so many
people
and i'm just imagining being an
asian-american kid
growing up in the 80s and 90s in your
case
uh you were born in in florida but then
you all moved to
new york and uh queens when you were a
teenager is that right
yeah i moved to new york uh it's about
to be 20 years
no this year is 20 years i moved to new
york when i was
um and there's an interesting tie
you know it's it's kind of like a uh
what do you call it like a bittersweet
reason because it was directly after 9
11.
so 9 11 happened and that triggered
a massive change globally right but as
it pertains to my own household we were
living in miami at the time i was born
and raised in miami
shout out to all the miami yanking out
there right
all the florida gang gang um but at the
time i remember the
the discussion in our household was we
wanted to be closer
to my um mama and yeah yeah
so that's grandma and grandpa on the
paternal side
so they came to america you know they're
of the 60s
70s generation so when they immigrated
to america
it was straight to new york straight to
the heart of chinatown
literally a hop skip and a jump away
from the world trade
so what happened was after 9 11 as my
mom and dad were discussing how did we
be closer to them
rather than uprooting them and bringing
them to miami the discussion was we go
up to new york
now at the time i had graduated high
school so i was like 18
turning 19 roughly and you know they
actually said to me
you don't have to come you know i mean
you're old enough now that you can
decide do you want to stay down here or
do you want to go
it was a no-brainer for me though
because i've always been like a
a home like a homebody you know i'm very
much attached to my family
yeah and also i knew that if i was gonna
make this
rap dream come to life in any way it
would be at the mecca it would be in new
york city
the birthplace of hip-hop you know so
you grow up
in miami uh you clearly are super into
hip-hop from uh
an early age uh and then i'd imagine
because your
your grandparents were in new york you
probably traveled to new york
periodically and visited them is that
right
often every summer every summer um
from from from a young young age but
most vividly in my mind
uh probably from eight years old on to
thirteen so like those five years you
know seven eight nine ten eleven twelve
every summer i'm in new york i'm running
around chinatown you know
um columbus park uh i'm all over like
east broadway a lot of a lot of trips
back and forth down east broadway
mainly because that was the route from
um
the the apartments that my my
grandparents lived in
to to the heart of chinatown um so yeah
a lot of vivid
fun childhood memories walking up and
down mott street
uh mulberry like a lot of memories
really really dope so you're into music
uh and it sounds like even as a teenager
you're like yo i think i want to do this
like
myself professionally i have to imagine
that your parents
were not thrilled with this
passion in their son because you know i
know a little something about
asian parents
all right so on that side of things um
yes there were several several
you know end of the world armageddon
level type you know just tensions
within our household surrounding this
particular
passion of mine um i think at its peak
was probably as i got older because when
i was like 12 or 13
it was very clear that i had an affinity
for this
because here are some like key points
that i remember i remember that when i
was 12 or 13
one thing that that was a a crucial
spark was
we went to this carnival in miami and at
the carnival there was like a booth
where you like a mobile recording booth
and they still have these now where you
basically pay like 20 bucks or whatever
they'll put you into the recording booth
they'll give you the lyrics to a
particular song that you pick
and then you can record it and you know
they'll give you a cassette recording of
it
so i remember i did this and it was a
side b side
on the a side i did ll cool j mama said
knock you
out i'm gonna knock you out and then on
the b
side i did crisscross jump
jump the mac daddy make ya jump jump uh
some of them chat around but they can't
rhyme like me right so the point i'm
trying to make is
as a 12 13 year old i don't think i
could have facilitated this myself so to
some degree my mom or dad
they had to have paid the 20 agreed to
this and let me do it
so i did that and i guess at that point
they they didn't realize that this was
the beginning
of something that would alter the the
rest of the course of my life
so i think the real tension didn't kick
in until i was maybe like
16 17 because at 16 17
i was very vocal to them about the fact
that
this is my path you know and uh number
one i think especially especially
approaching senior year
i was very straightforward about i you
know i'm i don't intend on applying to
any colleges and
that's not a tough one
for parents for parents in general but
in this case yes i think telling your
immigrant asian parents
that you know i'm not even taking the
sats
like if anyone even asked me yeah what
did what was your s.a.t scores jim
non-existent i didn't take it you know i
love the purity of this gin because
uh you know that this is like hey there
is no other path
like i'm not gonna like check it out and
see what that other path would look like
it's like this is what i'm doing
[Laughter]
there's a there's a beauty to it because
as i got older
uh eventually you know they came around
and i think it was you know in terms of
them coming around it was a combination
of just
you know at some point they had to
realize that well you know it's not that
we love our son any less
but it's just like this is his calling
this is his passion
you know and even though initially they
weren't a hundred percent on board
they did arrive at a place where they
accepted it my mom came around really
quick my mom was
like okay if this is something that he
really wants to do
you know she was on board for it my dad
dope uh his name is joe
he definitely was like i'm holding out
as long as i can
right and he he was not for but the
the quote-unquote happy ending is that
as far as right now
oh my gosh my dad is probably he's
probably more hip-hop he's more of a
hip-hop head than i am
right like he's like it's amazing it's
amazing
[Music]
[Applause]
this episode of yank speaks is brought
to you once again by outer known guys i
love this company so it's high
quality clothes with a great fit it's
founded by pro surfer and 11 time world
champion kelly slater
they're high quality they're sustainable
and they are comfy
af holy cow it's like i have a few i
have a pair of jeans and i have this
like
long sleeve like flannel situation and
it's so
comfy yang does all the time he loves
their flannels they're just super comfy
um they look good they fit well and you
know you're doing right
in the world so here's the deal go to
outernown.com today
and enter our code yang at checkout and
you'll get 25 off your first full price
order which is awesome so
outernoon.com that's o u t e r
k n o w n dot com and remember to use
our code yang at checkout for 25
off check them out today outernown.com
and don't forget
promo code yang 25 off
[Music]
[Applause]
did you perform two live audiences for
example in like your high school talent
show was there some evidence that you
actually
had the the these um uh
not just passions but also like frankly
ability
well i'll tell you this uh i i'll be the
first to tell you
like 14 you know 14 year old uh gin
you know it was one thing to mimic and
emulate the rappers that i loved right
in this case whether it's ll cool j
whether it's chris cross whether it's
whoever right but to actually
you're right what does it mean in terms
of my own craft like
are you writing your own raps gin are
you performing at the talent show
yes so to answer your question yes so
there were
several talent several talent show
experiences
i definitely started working on my own
compositions and i will be the first to
say
they were garbage they were hot trash
uh you know but everybody starts
somewhere and
um but i have fond memories of that too
of that process
uh because aside from the parents right
so you cover the asian parent side
but uh another fascinating aspect to me
is one reason why i loved hip-hop so
much
because there was a camaraderie to it so
my close circle of friends right like my
let's say close three four friends that
was like our clique
that was our little squad we were all
into the same things naturally
the nba we all loved playing ball and in
this case hip-hop
right like we just loved hip-hop and the
funny thing is these are some of my best
like bffs so to speak friends that i
still keep in touch with
to this day and i'm grateful for that
too you know we're all about to be
close to 40 right but i remember vividly
that even within this
small circle of friends these are my
brothers my comrades
they're like yo jim ain't nobody trying
to hear you rap yo nobody
no no nobody there were no you can do it
no no no these were not those friends
really the big question is like how the
heck
does someone break into the music
industry like you know as like a
19 year old kid like you you show up in
queens like what the heck was that
process like because for for me and i
remember
when you did start winning these rap
battles on b-e-t on 106 in park yeah
yeah 106 in park i think that was
uh like probably like a couple years
after you arrived in new york but that
that was
when you started hitting the radar of
popular culture and and
you know like people like me i mean i
feel like all along
i was looking for this big break so in
miami
i was already like you know as mentioned
before probably
a definitive moment was graduating high
school
so okay yes i don't have sat scores to
share
but i do have a graduation diploma a
pivotal moment was after graduating
i kind of already was full steam ahead
so this is in miami
i'm doing demo tapes i'm trying to get
into every
single battle competition that i can i'm
trying to get into every talent showcase
that i can
and i'm literally running around the
streets of miami
just battling like just freestyle
battling any and everywhere
at the mall at the movie theater at the
arcade everywhere
so i think the thing is when i made the
move to new york i was in the same
mindset
but just now it's a whole new playground
for me so i'm running around times
square battling like just like
who raps who raps i'll battle anywhere
uh in the village
there used to be a record store iconic
called fat beats
the corner of sixth and eighth where
there used to be a grace papaya
the graves papaya isn't even there
anymore but there was a record store
called fat beats
and i used to stand in front of the fat
beats record store
both freestyle battling and basically
selling mixtapes
like like uh yeah like mixed cds and
just be like i was that guy
i was that guy i was the hey yo you
listening to hip-hop yo check this out
check this out man
i was that guy so this is kind of the
the year or so
leading into the 106 in park to get on
106th and park you probably have to try
out or something
yeah i went to uh and i'm super like i
i have a strong vivid memory and it's
something that i hold dear to my heart
is the fact that
i went to just a traditional
conventional
open casting call along with the other
you know 300
you know hopefuls right the other three
roughly
200 300 people that had the same vision
as me like yo
i'm gonna get on this stage and this is
gonna be my big break
so i think that's the thing is like i
had always been looking for the big
break
and in this case the the 106 in park it
was the big break
you know so for those of uh uh you
listening who don't
know what we're referring to there was a
show on bet called 106th and park that
would just have rap battles
yes and you'd have a champion the
champion would come back every week
and so jyn ended up setting the record
for
uh how long someone reigned seven weeks
well there was
there was one guy i always like to i'm
i'm the guy that's always very adamant
about giving
proper credit to for me there was one
guy before me
that actually he he did the uh they call
it the seven
week run right and after seven weeks
there's this notion of like all right
this guy
he you know he's already proven himself
so we're putting him in the hall of fame
so there was a guy before me his name is
poster boy
so so i always like to acknowledge him
because
he he ran so that i could fly right so
shout out to poster boy well it's so fun
so after you win
seven weeks in a row they put you in the
hall of fame i mean that that's pretty
dope
so so you get up there you start winning
uh i'm gonna guess that uh of those two
to three hundred people you were
probably the
only asian american ding ding ding ding
ding ding ding
yo you clearly did the math
yes i um i i will attest unless unless
someone were to come out otherwise
because i clearly do not i would have
remembered
if i was there at that if i was there
you would have noticed like the other
issue
i would have noticed another asian dude
there if i was
like if i i remember on that day of
auditioning you know you show up
and you look around and it's just a sea
of rappers you know
from queens from brooklyn from manhattan
the bronx
staten islanders everywhere some even
from out of town
actually because everyone's just vying
for a spot on this stage to showcase
themselves
uh but yeah i think i would have
remembered if i saw another asian people
you would have remembered man
because you know
[Music]
okay if you're like me if you don't get
a good night's sleep
the rest of the day and sometimes the
week is horrific it's one of the most
powerful ways to improve your overall
health
and happiness get a good night's sleep
and if your daily routine has changed
it'd be harder to fall
and stay asleep and that's why we are
sponsored by calm
it's an app designed to ease stress and
get the best sleep of your life
and when you relieve anxiety improve
your sleep you feel better in every part
of your life they've got a whole library
of programs designed to help you sleep
you just open the app
press the button you get sleep stories
or soothing voices and all this
beautiful things coming out of it it's i
love it it helps me sleep
you go to calm.com you'll get a limited
offer of 40
off one of the calm premium
subscriptions which is hundreds of hours
of programming so
for our listeners of the show we're
offering a special limited time
promotion of 40
off of a calm premium subscription at
calm.com
yang that's 40 off unlimited access to
com's entire library
and new content is added every week so
get started today
at calm.com that's calm.com
yang
[Music]
[Applause]
so you win seven weeks in a row and then
shortly thereafter you become
signed to uh rough riders it's like a
major major rap label
um so was that directly off of uh 106th
and park yeah
so it's it there's like a fairy
tale-esque
aspect to all of this because
roughriders
as it stands was one of my childhood
like dream labels to be on
right like i think as a 16 17 18 year
old
your your dream is like okay how do i
sign with dr dre
how do i sound with you know the
neptunes or how do i sound with
rockefeller rough riders like i'm from
that era right like you mentioned i was
born in the 80s grew up in the 90s
so at the peak of my you know like
hip-hop journey
up to that point these were the end the
end game was to either yo
rockefeller rough riders who wherever
the door opens
so in terms of rough riders they
actually reached out
um before i won seven weeks so i think
maybe a little bit past the halfway mark
after i had won three or four weeks
they already reached out we were already
having uh conversations
and they were so committed and they
believed in my
i guess my journey so much that they
said hey if we can close this deal out
even before you win the seven weeks
yes yes they said after you win it
um they lit they kind of spoke it into
existence they're like after you win
on the seventh week right there is when
you will announce that you've signed
with rough riders
and this is all and i'm so grateful
because this is essentially all
documented and it's captured and it
lives forever
on film right so i win the battle and
the host
free and aj they're like yeah jin so man
congratulations you know how do you feel
right now
and i'm like how do i feel well i've
signed with roughriders
and i like and there's this iconic
moment that i forgot about
and recently someone brought it back up
to me uh on clubhouse
they were like gin i'll never forget
after you won the seventh week
you announced that you signed with
roughriders and you you you went in your
sweater
and you pulled out the rough rider chain
and you like put it in your mouth
and you bit on it and and i'm like damn
i don't even remember that
but apparently to this eight eighth
grader right he was probably in the
eighth or ninth grade at the time
he was like yo i'll never forget that
but the beauty of this is
it would be one thing if it was like an
asian kid right because i i encounter a
lot of that like asian
let's say male male and females right
that are in their 30s now
so at the time they might have been like
a junior high or a high school kid
and they'll tell me the the the story of
man i used to be
you know running home on friday to watch
it just to see someone that
remotely look like me so those tales i'm
always grateful and i cherish
but this particular story about the the
you pulled your chain out and you put it
in your mouth
it was a it was um a african-american
guy right that was like yo i was in the
eighth grade and for some reason jen
that moment has sit with him has sat
with me for like 20 years now
just when you pulled the chain out and
you put it in your mouth and you were
like yeah i'm rough riders now and i'm
just like
that's the power of you know like of of
cultural
connection you know i mean here you have
a chinese kid on
black entertainment television with a
young black kid
watching it but everyone's just like you
know just
connected and there isn't you know
necessarily like a feeling of like
yo this doesn't make sense it made sense
that it made sense to me on stage it
made sense to this eighth grader as he's
watching it
so i don't know like i cherish that i
cherish that
yeah it's a very universal uh like a a
universal
uh like underdog story honestly it's
like you know say it see
this person come up and then have them
be signed by
one of the major uh record labels
it's like made for hollywood stuff man i
mean i i like i like i
i remember uh frankly like hearing like
hey there's this uh asian guy who once
ever
did this and then he got sideways i was
like oh that's dope i i have some
friends who are asian american creatives
and a lot of them have to at some point
make a choice as to whether they're
going to try
to build their careers in asia or the
u.s
yes and so in your case after a number
of years
uh performing and releasing a number of
albums here in the us
uh you got drawn to asia and i'm
wondering about how that happened it
sounds like you had like one or two
events out there and then did you
discover when you were out there you
were like hey uh you know
like maybe i should like spend some more
time here
because i'd imagine out there uh well
i'm not sure if your
reputation preceded you when you got
there or whether
there were there were like fans uh you
know uh whether they were hip hop fans
i think you're one of the figures that
actually helped popularize hip-hop
in asia is that right i underestimated
the impact of that or maybe not
underestimated but i was oblivious to it
you know i mean i knew but i didn't know
until
later on so uh to circle back a bit yes
a defining moment for me in terms of my
overall journey
leading up to right now is actually when
i parted ways
with rough riders so i think that's a
good place to start at so literally
i signed with them in 2002 coming off
the 106 in park
we we go full throttle right uh we start
working on my album
my album comes out um in 2004.
so my first official debut as a rap
artist
uh is this roughrider released album
called the rest is history
so that came out in 2004 and
i gotta be honest like even just the
release of that album
and everything following that it took me
some time to process the
the highs and lows of that uh because i
think
number one there was just this
excitement that i think nobody had ever
seen before
and it did and it did kind of surround
the fact that yo
this is the chinese dude that was on bt
he's with rough riders now
and then there's this sense of like this
is something we've never seen before
so theoretically this should be gigantic
right something as simple as just the
notion of there's like billions of
chinese people
even if one out of every five of them
buy his album
that's like 200 million sales yeah
exactly so that
that was both both it i gotta be honest
it both
worked for me but against me it worked
for me because it created this sense of
like yo
this this is gonna be amazing not to
mention he is all rough riders
one of the hugest labels ever right so i
think
it worked for me in the sense of
creating excitement but it kind of
worked against me because it set this
expectation that to be honest was
somewhat unrealistic i guess right
and and everything i'm saying now is in
hindsight you know i'm saying it in
hindsight
but what happened was when the album
released for lack of better words
it definitely didn't hit nowhere near
that mark
that everyone had set for it to be
deemed a success
and what does that mean you know the
platinum plaques
the the accolades right the grammy award
the mtv award so none of that stuff was
uh
uh attained so in that sense there was
this feeling of like
did jin really live up to his potential
right so
i think upon me parting ways with rough
riders
even though it was a amicable split
right like i literally sat down with the
ceos of the label one day
and there was a mutual agreement that
hey
we gave it a go but we both feel like
this might be where we part ways
so we're part of the ways in that
fashion but to the general public
that's not exciting enough so to the
general public the more enticing
story is yo did you hear that jin got
dropped from rough riders so that just
became the
jen got dropped from rough riders jim
got dropped um so then for me
i had to spend a a a substantial amount
of time
processing that because of course the
rapper in me the young man in me
i was very defensive right so i was very
like yo man the industry is rigged and
you know everything is smoking mirrors
my
my frustration was not a rough ride as a
label but my frustration was with like
just the system and and that was a
defense mechanism to be honest
so i'm just like even through the music
i was releasing at the time
it was very bitter frustrated
anti-industry
anti-establishment i'm like yo i'm a
real emcee i'm a real mc right
so in hindsight i'm glad i had that it
was therapeutic
but underneath man i was broken and
underneath like meaning
there was this sense of like man i
watched my childhood dream come true
and then i kind of watch it fall apart
too so this is i i preface the asia
thing with that because i think it's
it's connected
so as um as i'm navigating through this
heaviness
there was like a good two-year period
where i'm like
i was this close to basically saying
this might not be it let me go to home
depot
let me go to yeah i don't know why i
always say home depot
because nothing not that i specifically
maybe i have a subconscious
interest in working at home depot but i
always always when i share this story
i'm like i was this close to going to
home depot and seeing if
i could get a job application right
because i'm like yo
i mean if this is not the path for me
i'm i you know i'm not gonna just
wallow and and just be unproductive i
still gotta go out there
and get a job now at that time i wasn't
even married yet so i wasn't married i
didn't have a family
so the the intensity of responsibility
wasn't extremely heavy but
here comes the opportunity to go to asia
uh specifically at the time
i started dabbling and rapping in
cantonese
which is um you know the language we
spoke at home growing up
so i'm grateful on that note too um but
i started dabbling rapping in cantonese
and then in 2008 i had a chance to go
and release an album in cantonese in
hong kong
and then one door opened to two doors
two doors open to four four into eight
and i spent like a good
four years there uh branching out into
stuff beyond music so acting hosting
things like that
and then the shift to come back was
actually when my first son
was born uh chance so we have a little
dude we have an eight-year-old
yeah we have an eight-year-old we have
an eight-year-old and a one-year-old
now at this point congratulations man
i've got an eight-year-old too
um and that that uh child being born
definitely does change things up
[Music]
[Applause]
all right this episode of yang speaks is
brought to you by stamps.com let's face
it taking trips to the post office is
probably not
how you want to spend your time and
that's why we recommend shipping online
at stamps.com which allows you to mail
and ship anytime anywhere right from
your computer
letters packages you name it and you pay
a lot less with discount rates from usps
ups
and more i'm a fan of this anytime i
need to mail something just stamps.com
very simple underneath the post office
save time save money
you can do it 24 7 any letter any
package any glass of mail anywhere
wherever you send so here's the deal
it's a freaking no-brainer so stop
wasting time going to the post office
and go to stamps.com instead there's no
risk and with our promo code yang
you get a special offer includes a four
week trial plus free postage
and a digital scale no long-term
commitments or contracts so just go to
stamps.com click on the microphone
top of the homepage type in yang that's
stamps.com promo code yang stamps.com
never go to the post office again
[Music]
[Applause]
so did you meet your wife while you were
uh
in asia so my wife is a abc like myself
american born chinese so there's a a
strong parallel
um in terms of our journey in that sense
her family came here from hong kong she
was born she's a true native uh native
new yorker
to the heart so she was born in new york
raised in new york
she's here she's a new yorker to the
heart she's probably
you know next to next to spike lee she's
right there in terms of nick's
supporting the mix so she's that
uh i met her of all places in puerto
rico
so i met her in puerto rico and it was
uh in
in the context of a hip-hop related
music seminar
so i was there to perform and she was
there as part of the organizers
and it's funny because i remember when i
showed up um
i walk up to the the registration
counter you know where you get your
badge and the itinerary and stuff like
that
and i looked at her and she looked at me
and i think our mutual kind of thought
was
we're probably the only chinese people
here right at this
it wasn't like um it wasn't like sparks
flying and you know it wasn't like that
but
we ended up crossing paths again later
on in new york
uh and then it was just like uh what do
you call it a traditional
courtship hey you want to go uh watch a
movie
and uh after the movie it's hey you want
to go get something to eat
you know so i think we watched like a
movie
almost like twice a week for that period
and you know it was dinner movie dinner
movie
and honestly when i went to asia uh for
that first
uh run to do the cantonese album we were
not
um we were definitely not married yet so
there were no kids we weren't even
engaged
i think it was actually after me
spending like a year or two in
hong kong that i was like what are you
doing jin
you know what i mean like there she is
she's right in front of you another
hollywood thing man you were like
i'm gonna go back go back and like go
back for
my girl like eventually my wife yes
yes so how was the time in asia i mean
it must have been an adventure
like you you know i think you did
something with like wang li home who i
actually kind of grew up with like you
know i went to
summer camp together and then yeah no no
really i know it's a small world
and then and so for him he like you know
went to asia to try and uh make the
music thing work and it worked out
um like so uh what was it like working
in the industry in asia
uh versus in the states yeah
so man lee holm's amazing by the way
super talented
and you know kudos to him actually
because he was
uh one of the first people to reach out
to me
and specifically you know kind of um
to extend the invite to work on music
together he literally was the first
so in terms of post 106 in park post
rough riders he was the first uh
artist in that uh in that aspect from
asia you know who had a huge following
and already fully established to reach
out to this you know
little rapping chinese kid in in new
york and say hey i'm working on my next
album
and i have a song that i totally can
hear you on and would love to invite you
on
and it wouldn't even feel complete if
you didn't jump on it so he was very
um inviting in that regard so shout out
to him
uh but the experience for me uh for sure
was culture shock
you know because i think um i had been
to hong kong
several times as a kid several times so
in the same fashion that i had a grandma
and grandpa in
new york i also had a gran i had
grandparents in hong kong
so as a child i i would frequent uh you
know vacation trips
to hong kong so it wasn't it wasn't like
a complete fish out of water sense
but i think the context of what brought
me out there was was crucial because now
i'm there as
a recording artist and now there is this
notion of
uh so this is you know every time i
would do a radio interview or a press
interview
i would be introduced as you know
straight from america the rapping
sensation
you know and you know there's this
there's this pre-built perception of who
i am already
uh uh a preconception of who i am
already which is you know he's born and
raised in america
or as they would call us there or i mean
i love the title
abcs right and what that means is even
right off the bat
i think not all but for the most part
there is a notion of okay he might not
be as chinese as us
he might not be as in touch with his
culture so when i'm doing these
interviews
something as trivial as let's say it's a
food interview right and we're sitting
at a restaurant
you'll hear the little jab that's like
hey you need a fork
you probably don't know how to use
chopsticks you need a fork hey somebody
get him a fork right
or just things like that you know and um
i took it in stride
like a lot of it i don't think it was
malicious but you know
every now and then you'll be like yo
like is that you know like
where is this you know and some of them
were really nice about it but i think
for some cases there was definitely like
uh i had to process it
and not take it personal you never feel
more american than when you're in asia
and like that same thing happened to me
you know here in the states you're like
well you know you're asian american and
whatnot you go over there and they're
like hey abc abc
all in all though all in all once i was
able to get past the culture shock
even for me uh it was great it was
amazing like i said it was
beyond what i expected in terms of
productivity
uh in terms of fruitfulness and more
importantly man just
me being able to come into
manhood i would even say that like come
into a space where i'm like i'm very
clear
um on what my purpose is what my passion
is
what my priorities are uh so it was
great and and honestly even in
hong kong specifically is where i grew
in my faith
like in in a way that completely caught
me off guard
yeah well it's beautiful man you come
back
you become a dad a family man
raising raising the kids in new york you
know you've branched out creatively
uh you're working on a bunch of
different things you're one in one of
the fast and furious movies
uh you you did uh you did a comedy
special that was uh released online yeah
and so i love the fact that you are
still expanding artistically
and creatively and you remain one of
like the true
trailblazers certainly uh for a lot of
people
uh what are you working on now and uh
what what can people uh expect to see
from you
so i think it's a very special time you
know for
myself and for our community right and
and i emphasize our community i mean
like as far as within the asian american
community
and i only say that because in terms of
like trailblazing right
you know and i'm very humbled whenever i
hear you say it because
i don't know i i i just feel like
sometimes the beauty in being a
trailblazer
in that sense is when you're not
necessarily setting out to do it
does that make sense i don't know i i i
get it man i mean like i
oh i never forget i ran i ran for
president and like it's like you're like
well you know i'm very very aware of the
fact that i'm the first
exactly bingo bingo
but but you're but i think the driving
force is
you you're balancing that combined with
what
just your core vision is right yeah so
it's like
it is a balancing act because even for
me
obviously it's nowhere near the scale of
running for president right but for me i
think as i reflect on my journey
it has been a complete balancing act
from beginning to end
which is how do i embrace my culture
but in a way you know do i want to be
defined by it
and it's and that's the thing you know
what i mean like i'm never i'm never
going to shy away from the fact that i'm
asian american
but at the same time i also don't want
to be just seen
only as yo you know he's an asian rapper
and that's why we need to pay attention
to him
it's a balancing act you know um but
i've learned to
find peace in you know just internally
so in terms of what's going on right now
you know i feel like there's a unity
within the community that i've never
seen
right and as far as everybody
galvanizing
their energies collectively to tell our
stories
to to have a voice so i'm excited in
that you know because
when i think of trailblazers for some
reason the first person to pop into my
head is clyde drexler
[Laughter]
so uh but i think you know to me
is there's a beauty in this is a real uh
real time epiphany that i've had
literally within these last few weeks
uh i i think i've always looked at my
journey as my journey right like oh this
is my journey i started rapping blah
blah blah
but unbeknownst to me yo my journey has
been
a lot of people's journey you know like
meaning when i encounter these
you know 30 year olds now and they're
like no jin i remember being you know in
the seventh grade as i mentioned earlier
so
it's dawning on me more and more now
that it's our collective journey
uh so i think i'm still in the music
zone i think music will always be at the
core of me
but in terms of like the acting i feel
like i'm only slowly tapping into the
acting thing
so hopefully there's more opportunities
in that regard uh
developing projects on my own as well um
and just pushing forward
you know pushing forward my own journey
and our collective journey
you know so yeah i mean you've been a
real
leader around the anti-asian violence
that's been occurring
uh you know you you um in at least one
case helped galvanize energy around like
a victim
of uh hate crime uh here in new york
uh and then you helped draw a lot of
attention to helping that person
yeah it's been it's been a really
difficult time uh but i have to say jyn
like your journey is not your own
you've inspired so many people and i'm
grateful that you and i become
friends over this time i'm incredibly
grateful to you
uh you've elevated uh
the last couple of years for me truly
and and having you
uh alongside me at some of uh these
events
um uh has made me so happy it's like
filled me with joy you're just like a
very uplifting person
uh and i and i think you know this
conversation actually helps
um explain like the journey you went
through because like you had so many
experiences that other people can like
you know
like can only faintly dream of what that
would be like
to to be like carrying like that the
mantle
of in some cases you know an entire like
uh
like multi-million like the hopes and
dreams of like oh like you know
uh of um like entire people
like artistically and then um
you know uh going through the ups and
downs of that and then having to to face
down what that
would be like um most of us can cannot
can't really imagine what that would be
like
and one thing that i i said at the last
event we were at is that we need to
support creators more because there's
something very very deeply personal
about you're trying to create art and
then put it out there uh you know we
need more of it in the world we need
more folks like you uh in doing the
things that you do
for sure and um that it's one reason i
was excited to have this conversation so
people could
frankly like humanize the the journey
that thank you undergone
thank you for having me man i'm excited
for what's to come for you
uh super excited excited to be part of
it excited to
collectively just push forward man
definitely fantastic jen let's do it man
let's show that there's no limit
people can do anything just like you
told your parents
like you know decades ago it's like
don't worry mom and dad like we can do
this thing
[Music]
yes
[Music]
you